[Music]
wake up early in the morning press play
and let's get it in cause we rocking
with the fighter
[Music]
doug i went to my normal barber and i
showed her you know
uh you guys probably don't know this but
as a white person you gotta be like hey
i'm going for it's super you feel so
lame doing it
you gotta take pictures of someone's
hair you like and show them so they know
what's up so i'll be
uh i had like four picks ready to go
that i got pinterest by the way i do
that same thing oh do you
so i was like yo this is this one i'm
going for i've been growing my hair out
for a hot
second leave the length on top and i
showed her she goes oh say no more and
puts it down like
did you even see it yeah i got it do you
want long and then the part i'm like
okay cool well and she's facing me so i
can't see the mirror she's talking you
know talking about covid
and black lives matter and it's like
getting heavy on like yeah no doubt all
right here we go
over there you can feel it no i'm like
yeah man i feel like there's a lot of
hair falling on my shoulder as your hair
leave
yeah as your hair leaves dog she turns
around i went
what and you you know you don't want to
be awkward because she's yeah she's my
friend and like
we're nice but she turned around i just
went ah [ __ ]
i asked for the length on the top and
she's like i know i'm sorry
i'm like oh i'm sorry oh god damn what
you mean
it was like i was like yeah he wants
that john cena no doubt like
he gave me the john cena yeah he gave me
the john cena the uk
it's short like and it's way shorter
here high's fine but she should have
left the the length on the top
yeah high and tight yeah you don't got
that ponytail no more
no i didn't want the ponytail i just
wanted length on the top
so i looked like a guy off love island
oh that's what she was going for
god damn it you're gonna love island and
then she's like well it goes back i'm
like yeah but it doesn't
it grows back but it takes forever yeah
i've been doing it in our grow fast it
does but to get like that length it
takes a while
yeah true i got [ __ ] coming up
out of all the weeks yeah out of all the
times to [ __ ] my hair up go ahead
this week we go out of town this week
yeah we go out of town this week
looks like i'm rocking a beanie for a
little bit yeah rock that beanie you
look good in beans
you pull
god it's frustrating you can't do [ __ ]
she turned me around
and she and what's weird is as she's
kind of i go man there's nothing worse
when you get a bad haircut
[ __ ] you can do that because it's the
worst damn
she should just cut the hair lights off
like hold on happy birthday brenden
just turn around i was like and you i it
was so awkward
you don't know what to do she knew she
[ __ ] up and i was like damn you [ __ ]
up all the lymph
yeah see i know it grows back i'm sorry
what did there's so i'm afraid i'm a
free agent you're a free agent did you
pay attention
oh yeah i paid her it's coveted it's
tough and like technically they're not
supposed to be open so it's like
she's doing it through yeah she's a good
person but it's like
i need to step my game up i gotta step
my game up
you know you're [ __ ] crazy we all
looking for barbers
we're all looking for barbers right i
need i need a straight stylus if you're
in the la area
you have a store or you do house calls
i'm a free agent we're shouting it out
i'm a free agent real talk
you know how to layer [ __ ] you know how
to fade well you told me not to listen
to fans they messed me up so this guy
you know
well if a fan is like yo my bar you're
out if it's a real stylist like yeah
i've been in the game 30 years
i work with blank blank blank then i'm
my people okay all right
yeah but if it's a fam like yo my cousin
gives the best philly fake
in her backyard yeah
be your friend i'm all set on friends i
was i was
heartbroken yeah and then i then i went
in the house my girl was like oh
man i was like what she's like ah it's
not good no
see that's how you know it's really not
good no hold on your girl says
that's messed up because haters yo your
girl supposed to lie to you at those
times because you can't get that hair
back
she's supposed to be like oh babe new
dude
no you gotta be honest no she do she was
like it's not bad she's like if once it
grows out more to be better how you want
i like how everybody keeps sending you
it once it grows out more
yeah i want now heartbreaking
i will try to find one in austin
yeah just clean me up you always do it
when we get to the cities you don't want
to do in la before you leave huh
which is weird because it's always a
struggle everything is always hashtag
booked
yeah it is tough around here yeah it's
tougher here you look like militia daddy
who moisha the dad on maui i really like
motion daddy
oh that was uh brandy's show right yeah
yeah
mozzarella you and i have the same hair
right now we do have the same hair
brush he's depressed like
y'all should do the reinvention a new
classic no
it's heartbreaking well it's just like
it's like that's like that's like going
to a restaurant like i want steak
and then they bring [ __ ] fish like
that's not what i asked for
yeah and then be like oh i [ __ ] up you
gotta eat it though
all right i guess i'll eat it yeah i
have to pay i'm not going to steal it
that that's the thing that sucks
like there's literally nothing you could
[ __ ] do nothing it was the length
where well but as far as they're like
there's nothing you and you didn't want
yours that short nah i did not
y'all clown me because i had a bald spot
you didn't remember i remember i
remember the jokes
yeah because the guy i feel like yours
is a little easier than mine bro no no
no no you should have waisted no
your hair is easier than all right
exactly i was just about to say yeah no
don't make
my length no no yes your hair is way
easier than um no let's not do this we
can't go anywhere
thank you you could go anywhere bro i
i'm sorry i can't go
if you're gonna you're not long here
there's you can't just go to anybody
you need and then also you guys can go
like a barber right that fades a video
but but yeah
dude i need a [ __ ] i need stylist bro i
can't walk into some rant
i can't go to floyd's barber shop and
ask them to [ __ ]
give me they do that they didn't do that
they do that that's that low level [ __ ]
bro
no it's not i don't it is ain't look
over what for for if you i'm like
i need some i need some [ __ ] you need an
elevator [ __ ]
okay okay there's great clips yeah right
there's great clips
super cuts nope super cots
they're super cuts they're super cut
there's great clips in the middle okay
then there's floyd's little highland
great clips
and then there's the real deal okay you
need to really i need that john cena
yeah leonardo dicaprio that's what you
need okay like an american barbershop
have you heard of that place
no this is how it's over like that's
really far from you yeah
but if it's a good cut because when my
hair is long i only go there once every
three months i'll drive down there
true i mean let me actually seriously oh
you don't get your hair cut that often
not when it was when it's long chappelle
when it's long he had to grow it
again he listen what he did was they
just edge it up right that's like going
to the dealer and be like hey
i want a jeep yeah and they bring around
this [ __ ] prius and you're like
i didn't want an electric car i wanted i
got you i'll ask for a jeep like
my batman i ran your you got you own
this now
you own this and you're like okay
see ya but you would you did you ever
really do your hair like this
never nah yeah but never dude you could
see that i showed them picture
that's i was i want to make sure they
didn't [ __ ] walk
yeah yeah yeah yeah okay pictures i
don't know did you keep taking this are
you taking the show
can you take us through it again we went
to nashville i showed that dude the
picture yeah but
what'd you show a picture of uh i was
like i do my hair like this and he was
like
it's good above and beyond yeah it's
good if they ask a lot of questions
yeah my girl went like this say less
well no i'm not asking for a shaved head
like there's a lot they go there's
layers [ __ ]
yeah you gotta really focus you yeah i
got this i'm like
this is not [ __ ] you can't because like
girls like
yeah like you guys can't go to grade you
can't just go to great groups no
with girls you have to really find like
that one it's similar to having a barber
you have that one hairstylist that you
go to and you only go to her yeah you
don't go to her you go to someone else
she knows when you cheat because you
come back with a [ __ ] up haircut yup
yes my sister does hair she
cursed them out oh when you she cursed
them and she actually add more still do
your hair but they're
they're like more kind of fuss about it
like see what happens when you leave
go somewhere else like freddie negrete
did all mine
yeah and i had a guy do another one and
he was going oh he's like
and i could i was like kind of stressed
out about it well because he you know
he's freddie mcgretty so he got a book
in like months in advance yeah 100 he's
a beast
so i just got like a one-off like easy
tattoo and he was going i could see he's
getting it because he did the sleep and
he had to go around it and he he's
getting on yeah
[ __ ] and he's all where'd you go for
this one
what i was like dude i didn't want to
bother you that hold me up the street
did it
he went like this he went he went it
ain't good
just finished the outfit he goes you
want me to go over it i'm like that'd be
nice
so he like put his touch on oh really
yeah he went it ain't good
he goes to a homie up the street for a
tattoo i panicked you panicked yeah
yeah you need one legit like a girl like
it's so important
for a guy too it's like we just go to
walk into floyd's
there's [ __ ] eight people it's like
oh yeah next up
but you get what you paid for exactly
[ __ ] up man you know what won't you be
like chin he cuts his own
nah need that short hair though i shaved
it all off though dude
i'm talking about that brad pitt hit her
that's what leonardo dicaprio
every time you look like a dying piece
yeah listen i know bad hair days hashtag
nobody now you just look confused
now it's like you look like you're
having a discussion yeah yeah yeah
it's like oh is that is that john cena
peanut butter falcon johnson yeah peanut
butter
john cena [ __ ] dude yeah damn well i was
so heartbroken i walked in and just was
like
my girl was like damn i was like well at
least connor's fighting tonight
oh it was on my birthday oh what'd you
do for your b day man no i just went
through
i told you happy birthday probably first
more than anything yeah he was the first
one
early what time 12 minutes about stephen
three o'clock in the afternoon oh yeah
happy birthday stephen
it's three in the afternoon yeah my
birthday's over that means you forgot
yeah you're out dude my birthday's over
he's not watching friday's episode i
mean we shouted that birthday out the
whole come on man
cat what'd you do for your b-day i just
went to my homie's house in riverside
man did your girl go with you
yeah chilled kicked it hung out did the
damn thing then yeah
let me tell you something yeah we had to
oh bro guess they're the worst gifts
it's so awkward no you like gifts i love
gifts you do love gifts
it's just like okay yeah but your girl's
getting like a tv
i'm talking about like gifts when like
put a lot of thought into it yeah
don't think something you don't want
first of all don't give me a card oh
that's a [ __ ] car unless
dude it's not 1984. don't send me
cards don't send me cards don't send me
your [ __ ] family's christmas pictures
no okay
don't send me your wedding advice i must
have a prison mentality shoot
me all alone give me a text message
shoot me a text shoot me that's what i'm
saying shoot me a text message so
don't shoot me on holidays my birthday
stream it takes don't give me a text
holidays don't text me on
thanksgiving christmas yeah yeah bro
well okay we're all doing it oh awesome
my for my close friends and family don't
text me
after a conor mcgregor fight like man
what do you think happened
i told you this is a show on monday yeah
listen i don't want to go through this
every time
like right when i walked in mark sanchez
who i love ghosts dude
tell me what happened i go dude just the
show will be on a few hours
do i really have to rehash it yeah just
give me the cliff well it was funny
because
i was gonna say something in the group
text but i was like you know i'll just
save it i was like he'll probably talk
about it we were all it was uh it was it
wasn't even
it was uh the ryan garcia pacquiao thing
oh that's fake
is that real fake that's fine we went
over today isn't it it'd be hard to do
fake
because he's like right he's so into it
yeah she is
that's not fair it's destroyed by many
people okay but but it's two different
promotional companies right can we both
agree
yeah but sometimes that happens all
right all right especially if you're
manny pacquiao's work
right now let me make sure okay al
haymon doesn't do business with
oscar de la hoya like yeah this is
strange man oh he's just putting the
energy out he's putting that energy so
it's not real
he's the one who can get probably can
get manny pacquiao i don't know
don't think so yeah i i think manny
would take it dude
dude i think manny beats the pistol beat
the brakes off them yes a hundred
percent
i don't know maybe maybe it's a move to
try and lure like tank or
not tanks wants to fight but again i
guess i say his promotional company i
remember once
with boxing yeah earl smith said the
same thing with terence crawford he was
like bro you're on the wrong side of the
street
pbc is where you should be signing
that's the problem with boxing yeah like
like
the fighters want to fight but the
promoters yeah it's just some people
they they all have their own interests
so you don't get the fight you want to
see it's the number it's why boxing is
dying
yeah yeah but again that'd be a dope
yeah yeah i don't i don't think around
to see if it actually no
i didn't no we did it from the show
today there's no there's no official
word
official oh okay that's a weird thing to
do because
that is a weird move especially the
poster i want to thank mike because he's
like thinking his team and behind the
scenes so it seems legit well he's a
young kid he lies
that's a bad luck man if that's just not
real and you're making posters
he made a poster because because then
what happens well to take when he's
trying to lure out this one's like oh
it's official
blah blah blah but if it doesn't happen
and then he fight let's say he doesn't
fight tank or kanye or
like if he doesn't fight a big name and
then they give you just some no name
everyone's like
it just makes you look bad it was like
dude what the [ __ ] happened yeah what
up in the tank what happened to manny
and you're like oh no i'm fighting this
other dude but he could say
he could lie behind the promotion uh oh
look yeah a dream turn reality
oh okay i guess it's just some flyer
he's dude number one he made him
photoshop
number one comment duck and tank shaking
my head
but again so you put that energy out
there you just said you put that energy
out it's just a bad look yeah
because you're going for tang yeah for
manny you're all over him you scattered
yeah and then he to be honest you
shouldn't be fighting either those guys
yeah and then if you fight a guy you
should be fighting everyone's
disappointed yeah like it's not a good
luck yeah that that's happened
so that's happened to fighters where
it's like only in boxing never involved
ufc you post that poster it better be
real
and also if you announce a fight before
the ufc
dude dude you're in trouble you're in
trouble
some guys i mean dude i'm talking big no
no can i let me so like has that
okay so so ryan ryan's uh uh
up and coming dude he's doing really
good right now a guy like that like
so if he fought like manny and loses
does that like
drop him down no no man he's such a
legend he's so
young he he wouldn't even canelo versus
mayweather thing let me ask you this
oh it's like that yeah yeah that's
exactly what it's like so let me
actually do this but
maddie's even older i know he's old and
then also many knock your ass out and
he's still
just me thurman it's so
weird it's like all right i guess you
want that he thought everybody get his
ass little by terence crawford let me
ask you this
would you would you put if we're talking
about sports terms is mma
more the nfl and best and boxes more
like the nba because
the nfl is the brand like no one is
above the brand
right because you have the helmet's nose
and you have stars in basketball you
have stars in boxing
so they can release fights without their
promoter you know promotional company
i'll tell you when to release it but you
just said
that yeah ufc is the nfl okay i got you
all right where's the brands bigger than
the fighter
okay connor kind of dabbled in that now
he's lost he's kind of fell off that
mountain but yeah
yeah you're right yeah yeah nba it's
about the players but the players the
stars
like whether they went to another league
they went to china like we're going to
watch those games because they're
superstars because they're superstars
boxing people don't have enough stars
that's their problem well well
no i think they're there's only a
handful well it's a it's that division
that lightweight division
that's popping yes then you have a few
heavyweights we want to see he's about
to go there canelo's the king
yeah it's just more it's just like
there's not enough it's just
they can be stacked with superstars yeah
ufc
stacked with stars but they now they're
kind of controlling them like
they don't want anybody get too big for
their matches because of connor okay
because connor he's the one who's going
to the game he's abandoned and made up
you know
took over the game wait let's talk about
you guys watching you
oh talk about what was texting you lost
during the fight yeah you lost a bit
yeah i lost two bets this weekend i took
i took so you
you he's you hear this you're here first
oh this is breaking news so just so no
one comes at him when he doesn't
i lost i lost i took the bills off the
alumni
[Music]
would i traditionally do that probably
not oh yeah yeah so
you won the first one so you won that
one and then they got stomped and then i
bet
the the connor poirier bet was more it's
like an entertaining
more thing because theo is super close
with dustin poirier yeah yeah i'm a
connor dick rider so i was like oh i bet
you're grand
and i brought the cash but um that's
more for entertainment
i told her like i did big really shows
like tsn in toronto
with me and luke thomas like this fight
the odds vegas had three to one it
should not have been three to one
it was an even fight yeah it should have
been even money
but you you had said like if it's like
if you said if dustin got past
that first round then he could probably
take it yeah you said that you called
that he took him down called
that too hey i want to ask you a
question right i was studying
heartbreaking if you're a connor fan
that fight was heartbreaking but because
we've seen him lose but he always
he only loses by submission he's never
lost so it's always like oh no one's
going to knock him out that's his thing
they gotta take him down
then he gets knocked down the feet like
damn i got nothing but the game
the game has my friend was telling me
the game has changed who's your friend
these are the conversations i have at
starbucks who's your friend who's your
friend it's my friend like man i heard
oh yeah who's your friend my guy hey
well he's on the share dog forums
i'm not dude i'm not having this
conversation
he walks around his key all day he
watches his fights in the ghee
now he was saying like it's like andrew
schultz texting man i i think
the power doesn't translate at 55. i
think he's born at 40
yeah he's stopping him i said you ever
seen him at 55 when he's in his prime
you ever see him fight eddie alvarez
you ever seen that conor mcgregor it's
the best 155 on the planet we've ever
seen
yeah but then money and fame and he went
and did his thing and then try to come
back to the game
ufc especially at lightweight you can't
leave and do other things
and be happy yeah you know have money in
the bank and come back and be
competitive you can't
it's you can't be like my my on my
analogy on below the bell it's like
it's like tom brady a year ago playing
one quarter
like in like beating who's a real shitty
team like
miami dolph is about there miami is
pretty good but like last year
last year miami was back with
jacksonville let's just say jacksonville
so it'd be like tom brady balling out
against jacksonville
but for one quarter and then taking a
whole year off and then playing the
super bowl
and then be like i guess i'll bet on
that tom brady from that one quarter
uh when patrick mahomes has been bald
we've
been in it beating some of the best
going through the playoffs
we know he's he's battle tested yeah
he's ready to go yeah firing all
cylinders
but then you're better on tom brady we
haven't seen he's probably rusty
the game's not game ready you don't know
what that's all
actually the game has changed because
the front leg kick and i think that
we've been
oh okay your friend tell your friends
that front leg kick has been going on
forever
why did they why did they make a big
excuse like he's not checking it and he
like
he wasn't checking it because he hasn't
been fighting because he's been so
focused on boxing
his his connor used to be the best
because we didn't know what was coming
you remember in uh in rush hour when
chris tucker gets kicked he's like
okay which one do you offer me that was
conor mcgregor like you didn't know what
like you didn't know what was gonna
happen he was like so dynamic he was
fluid
now he's straight boxing just boxing
like not working on kicks and that's and
he got taken out by kicks
but for people like he he's been kicked
a million times it's stupid
so people just like no it's stupid he
just wasn't he he didn't
and to not to defend connor here he
asked the ufc
multiple times he even forced a
retirement because he's like dude i want
to fight
fight me i don't want to just fight dust
and poi like let me fight diego sanchez
let me fight this guy
i'll fight whoever but give me ring time
and they just didn't give fights
they're like oh here's number two
lightweight in the world and he's like
all right [ __ ] it
damn why why again so the brand the
brand is bigger than you
would don't you have to say so like bro
brandon's not bigger than connor
still not but why did he take that fight
he was like bro no other options they
thought it was a good fight
i think that if they [ __ ] up on his
side i think the ufc [ __ ] up
if you remember that fight started off
of uh a charity boxing match
yeah because connie didn't get a fight
yeah and so dustin has a big charity and
they're like dude let's do a
amateur boxing match where he's money
for charity they both agree they come up
with a date then the ufc hijacks he goes
nope
all right we want in now if you oh no
we'll do it
uh all right all right that's why you
paid on the 000 oh
okay all right damn so where does connor
go from here
i don't know you watch his post fight
and he doesn't seem like he wants to do
it yeah
yeah he's out he's just different level
he's yeah here's what's crazy he seems
happy
you know what i'm saying yeah like that
fire to be the best isn't there
you happy dude you're on a yacht yeah
gucci like you made it dude once you
shave your hands
yeah like to if i'm his friend like you
[ __ ] those guys shave your head you've
done everything yeah you've done
everything like what
what are we doing now you can only hurt
your legacy like why keep doing it dude
yeah
get on the yacht you have another baby
coming [ __ ] it dude focus on your
whiskey
yeah like what what are we doing yeah
why are you doing this and even
like after lost he's like man i just it
doesn't mean that much to me like it
feels different like oh you're out
yeah you're out dude yeah you reached
the pinnacle of success yeah leave
there's no reason to keep doing it no i
got completely understanding you know
what the [ __ ] he wants to do but if i'm
his friend like dude come on
why are we doing this why are we doing
this did you watch the fight
no i didn't get to watch it right you
didn't see it i was around i was texting
each other
during the fight yeah i was uh with
little brows we just i just saw that oh
you watching the little brown i wanted
to see uh
uh chandler oh yeah bro come on
up and balled
did you guys watch it the fights yeah
i'm surprised stevie
i'm sure steve you watched it yeah yeah
it was stevie my sister and i watching
it
and we were just eating cereal all night
cereal oh snaps football fans
the moment we've all been waiting for is
around the corner in february
and it's all happening at draftkings the
official daily fantasy partner
of superwall 55. it's uh they're
bringing back their golden ticket
giveaway with up to 55 million dollars
in prizes up for grabs all you have to
do is get your share of these huge
prizes
enter draftkings free super bowl
prediction challenge
once you submit your picture you will
get a free instant prize up to 25
000 bucks if you have the most
predictions correct you could win the
top prize
of one million dollars download the app
now enter the free prediction
challenge answer questions like cool
score last and boom
get ready to make it rain baby
draftkings has paid out over seven
billion dollars to his players since
2012
so they know a thing or two about big
paydays uh
download the draftkings app now use the
promo code fighter
enter the free 55 million dollar super
ball prediction challenge
everyone gets an instant prize up to 25
000
just for playing so use the promo code
fighter right now and
enter the free 55 million dollar super
bowl challenge only at draftkings
the official daily fantasy partner of
super ball 55 terms conditions
apply see draftkings.com for details all
right insurance can be complicated
that's why
the zebra was created when you use the
zebra.com insurance
finally feels like it's in black and
white no more confusion no more grayers
just honest rates from real
companies the zebra's nation's leading
insurance comparison site
for cars and home insurance they can
help you save money today it's so
freaking easy
just go to the zebra.com answer a few
quick questions
compare accurate insurance quotes for
free the zebra protects your personal
information all right
you can secure your insurance from the
zebra.com over the phone
um from one of their licensed insurance
agents super easy over the phone
the with states reopening and people
back on the road the zebra is committed
making sure your family
is covered how much money can you save
on car and home insurance
visit the zebra.com fighter that's
t-h-e-z-e-b-r-a-dot-com
fighter for insurance in black and white
did you guys watch it the fights yeah
i'm gonna say i'm surprised stevie i'm
sure steve you watched it yeah yeah
it was stevie my sister and i watching
it and we're just eating cereal all
night
cereal yeah we decided to have cereal
got money now what are we doing i know
i love cereals
thank you for your money we got money
now cat cat's all we can see it with
water
you should have heard her earlier she
was like i came from a 29 house uh
people household twenty five people in
the house yeah you got money now
you're conor mcgregor of only fans what
are you doing
hey i'm going back to syria's
foot down what kind of what kind of
stuff we got
okay so stevie had kind of like a weird
cheerio he likes fiber
fiber
no stop stop
you can't come to san marcos bro i like
how you're expecting like
okay where are we going captain crunch
where are we going we had a
[Applause]
okay so he came in and asked us what
type of cereal did we get my sister got
cinnamon toast crunch
through loops i love crunch and reese's
pieces
i also love you the recent piece is a
little sketchy that one i wanted cocoa
puffs but i couldn't find it i said
steve stevie get and then stevie got
fiber one and for
frosted flakes what did i say frosted
flakes hot as [ __ ]
fiber one
and did he get it with the dehydrated
strawberries
hey stevie what do you not need
that's unreal out of all the
choices you guys went to ralph's no we
went to target
oh unreal that's what happened i
normally back stevie on his
you know his eating habits and i think
it's great no one got fruity people i
can't i can't
lucky charms they sold out for some
reason the target was empty that day
i don't know what it was they didn't
have [ __ ] that day really yeah i don't
know what
maybe they needed to restock but they
just didn't have a good one i'd rather
go
hungry than eat fiber one i'd be like oh
all right well
i'll just share yours but if you find me
like what else do you expect
from what i didn't expect i honestly did
not even even in prison they didn't give
him five or one
yeah and he chooses that
if you eat fiber one you just climb
ladders you could have done the reason
check
the checks you could have done [ __ ]
frosted flakes
honey you couldn't even realize
even raisin bran goes hard yeah even
yeah the scoop
stevie honey honey bunches and oh
something
you know what a fiber one five or one
who what old folks home
did you did you did you eat some of it
the fiber one i tried some of it not for
you again
you tried it though i tried it it's not
terrible but it's not like a cereal i
would ever go for
it's not it shouldn't be you ever [ __ ]
with the big
it's one big thick wheat bran man this
is vaccine you need to hurry up and come
up oh yeah shredding
what are you talking about there's
shredded wheats but there's one biggest
the small ones where it's like
the fried cereal you talk about freshest
frosted shredded wheats
yes and then there's the regular one
which is a little shorter frosted one
squares come on oh there it is shredded
wheat that big old
one from the box though
when you [ __ ] it comes out just like
that
it's so
dude i challenge anyone to eat that on a
hot summer's day
it's so dry oh it's oh it's time to eat
huh it's insanely bright
better money i won't get that in uh san
marcos to eat it
okay so what's drier this or popeye's
biscuit
oh popeyes is dried too
and i thought because the kids they
couldn't put some cartoons on the cereal
anymore
i don't know they still had cartoons but
i think there's something with
advertisement that you yeah like there's
a kids fda like get some weird things
maybe you can't offer the toys anymore
there's some rule heaven forbid chin
should have a computer and look it up
anyways she was like i wish i had
something to google it or something
anyways what are you talking about uh
can you put
kids toys and cereals anymore do they
put kids toys and cereals anyway yeah
there's like regular there's something
is
have the kids eating the sugary uh
cereal yeah really oh
sorry my kids my kid doesn't need it
he's never had any of the sugars here so
there's only one
he only has the regular cheerios oh wow
not the honey nut you're not gonna let
him live nah
wait till he finds out i've been
watering down his juice
he's gonna you've been watering the nuts
oh yeah there's so much sugar and apple
juice and orange juice
i put like a quart of juice in the rest
water yeah at the same time if that's
all he knows that's fine yeah but wait
two dries the real thing
all right oh it's gonna be like what the
[ __ ] oh his tooth
i knew he saw that yeah oh did joanna
post it yeah
yeah his tooth fell out and uh we were
at uh whole foods
um and he was biting in an apple and he
was eating an apple and then we're
driving he's like damn my tooth hurts
michael's throwing your tooth and he
goes like this his tongue starts
wiggling like oh [ __ ] your tooth is
loose
yeah i shouldn't let you eat that apple
and i was like was it loose before he's
like maybe a little
and then it kept bothering me he's like
dad pull it out and he was gangster
about it he's like
oh he was yeah he was like dad someone
must told me he's like dad tie a string
and uh put the other string you just put
the other string on your porch and then
take off and
yank the tooth i'm like i ain't doing
all that i was like let me get a paper
towel
and i kept messing with it and i get
squeamish that stuff i'm like uh it's
not ready man just let it fall out
then his grandma was like [ __ ] that and
he was like yeah i want it out grandma i
went out she's like all right
she's like he's gonna hurt he's like i
don't care i want her down like damn dog
she ripped it out damn did he cry
not at all damn well he's all gonna
start telling about the tooth fairy
i was gonna say you gotta do the tooth
fairy thing there bro did i
[ __ ] up though with the tooth fairy so
what i did i had him write a note
he wrote a note to the tooth fairy yeah
and then uh he folded that
and then i have these little mini
orioles that he loves that he only gets
on special occasions so i was like oh
tooth fairy dope gives them that but
they're
it's a package right it's like a loud
package so i put his note with the
cookies
and then i was looking for cash did you
get i'm like two fairy gives cash she's
like how much i'm like i don't even know
anymore
with inflation i don't know my dad you
should give me a dollar
taxes with two favors
i don't know what it is dude in 86
a dollar was different than his today so
then i was like i have cash but i didn't
have any one i have no singles all i had
was a 10. i'm like i guess i'll give
this little bastard ten dollars
he was crunk oh hell yeah but i saw
she's another one
we were trying to sneak in and put the
cookies and the note and the ten all
under his
bed and the cookies were [ __ ] making
all these noises so he popped up
yeah the gig is like what y'all doing
what the [ __ ] is going on
there [ __ ] the two fairy got drunk
that's no i was like i was gonna give
you cookies in the morning
okay and then i like snuck out and then
his mom went back and just put the ten
dollars there
and then five in the morning papa i'm
away here every morning pop i'm awake
cause we have a camera yeah yeah so i go
in there he's like look what the tooth
fairy gave me ten
dollars get that thing now you're gonna
buy more or no that's the standard
ten dollars yeah 20 what do you have 26
teeth
260 bucks for his [ __ ] teeth i don't
remember getting like no [ __ ] 10 ten
dollars
yeah he's playing quarantine playing
quarantine he's like i'm gonna buy stuff
he's i'm gonna send some uncle jay oh
my boss and stuff like dude it's ten
dollars
with the real this dog is ten but i love
his mentality though yeah
take care of his family that's love bro
yeah so what uh uh
there's these special oreos you were
saying they're the mini ones
that's bad and they're only 100 calories
and 11 grams of sugar
i used to eat that cereal i would put
the mini uh
cookies in a bowl and then put milk over
it as well
did you do the golden ones or did you do
the right i used to do the chips ahoy
and mix it with oreos
my fat ass you take the double stuff
oreos
take the top off and make them quadruple
stuffed oh
oh i see what you do you like that extra
cream oh i love it creamy
that hair yeah with that hair you love
it
we both love it you got the same
guess what i found out about myself go
ahead brother okay
so i'm allergic to shellfish and avocado
okay
i've had avocado in like i don't know
years all right probably like 10 years
no guacamole yeah yeah nothing i don't
like it i don't know yeah it's a shame
gotta
got a burrito yesterday from tacos to
madre
yeah don't say it like that yeah
okay anyways i'm sitting here eating
this burrito
it's so damn good right you get into the
middle of it
that's the best part guacamole [ __ ] it
what you did yeah
finish that [ __ ] i was too hungry i
didn't even say [ __ ] to nobody because i
was like
because all my friends know that if i
[ __ ] eat
though they're gonna freak out or
whatever and like i'm like bro this is
too [ __ ] was there an epipen anywhere
no dude here's the thing i was fine yeah
you [ __ ]
what what been a [ __ ] about guacamole
no i haven't bro i'm telling you i used
to get so [ __ ] up from it and now
you're good
yeah i'll groove it down that's what i'm
thinking right now we go straight
because you can do that
your body's ready to go down you outgrew
all this [ __ ] yeah but wait
all right maybe we could do some some
crab in texas i don't know
i don't know but like maybe just try
once what does it say after the show
eighty percent of people with egg eight
percent people with egg milk wheat
allergies outgrow them usually by age
16.
about 20 25 children with penile's
outgrow them 80
who outgrow them will do so by age 8.
algaes to tree nuts fish and shellfish
may be tougher to outgrow
and are often lifelong often well we'll
see wait wait wait wait
we got shows to do we'll see we got show
we got shows
joe's crab shack all right so first
okay but that's w i grew up yeah dude i
didn't freak out another
and i was like i wasn't going to stop
the burrito was [ __ ]
yeah it's worth dying for huh oh yeah
yeah oh yeah
[ __ ] it all right you know what i need
to do i need to open up a [ __ ] wing
chop because my girl got an air fryer
congratulations bro congratulations yes
dude [ __ ] a conventional oven
[ __ ] a microwave for this air fryer this
alien
magic that cooks your food now really
yeah dude yeah the way everybody's been
talking about
you know how you get like uh you know
how you get like extra crispy wings from
wingstop
they're not that crispy dude these wings
from the airfryer
my girl does a lemon pepper sauce on it
and right here
no wet a wet she does a wet lemon pepper
sauce
so she seasons it puts lemon pepper on
it puts in the deep fryer
halfway through takes it out lathers it
up with my mouth as one
lathers it up with lemon pepper sauce
then once they crisp
with the golden crisp and there's no oil
or nothing it's healthy
then once the it's out then she douses
in the hot sauce
are you serious your mouth is watering
bro
i do the will my girl don't do the
airfryer with the barbecue damn now i
want some wings
they better have something to my girls
watching uh tutorials on youtube on how
to cook the wing stuff so she made her
own
uh lemon pepper sauce i was like we need
we need to take this
i hear it i hate i hear it that's what
people do now they just cook everything
in an air fryer oh dude
you made like chicken strips like
healthy
tenders that's what i was gonna say i
heard it's not it's really good there's
no grease
no it's way healthier cleaning it out
it's tough i hate cleaning oh not ours
wait what do you mean it's just trays
yeah what kind of you guys you got an
off-brand dog no
yeah no you got the off-brand she bought
it i said
we'll never use ovens again not because
how much tiger always
chicken tenders so we'd have to heat up
the oven get now dude
about six minutes they cook fast too and
then here's the best part
pizza chicken wings or steak all in
there yeah when you want to reheat it
it makes it crispy it's like yeah soggy
like your microwave and you don't need
to like put
oil or anything on it it's mad we got
the sleep what have i been doing
i got the 99 100 one well this one yeah
bro what the hell what you pay for me
um wait i don't see my oh
you know i i think i have mine's more
like that one now you just went on to
that the
that one this one that's what i have no
yours was different yeah yours was like
a little box
and even ours isn't that when ours has
like three levels to it
and then you just pull the tray it's
easy you see the tray you got to clean
that out at the bottom no
it's super easy yeah that yeah you don't
have that one mallet
when we get back from texas i'll tell my
girl make those wings oh come on she
does barbecue
lemon pepper and hot are you serious
game changer and then so she made him
they looked
fire like damn those look pretty good
and she was like well i just want to do
a test for everyone comes over for the
connor fight
so i think you're like thursday or
friday night she made him
we sat down to watch love island oh i
missed half the episode just
in the wind just deep sodium these hot
wings to him
you deep throat oh yeah yeah sure that's
the name of your restaurant
hey do you get all the stuff off the
wing no i don't know listen there's too
many wings what am i doing yeah right
what are we doing i can't do the whole
[ __ ] that's some
i mean you know there's more wings some
people like the they're just the bone
left oh yeah i can't do that
some people even eat the bones don't
like the balls what i suck at the marrow
that's disgusting it's not it's good
it's delicious he's tripping my best
friend
there's too many wings
if i mean crab legs and little crab legs
give me problems see them right
i'm on to these fat flocks it's like the
same with pistachios
all the way open yeah me too i'm out
but asians y'all appreciate it wants to
act all tough
throw that [ __ ] i know your asians
appreciate food because i was when i'm
my best friend she's asian and she'll
clap every time your best friend what's
her last name
florence oh okay i'm not very excited
ah she's not asian is she filipino yeah
wait is she filipino though because
filipinos tend to have like spanish last
names
you don't even know your best friend
like that you don't know what type she
is she's from santiago
so uh santiago yeah did you hear how you
just said that
she is not very asian yeah she is okay
is she clapped from the food you ever
instagram
is that asian or not when they clap on
the food that's more of like a racist
thing hollywood used to
dude well no she does it so i i know
it's not hold on before i get it
yeah oh she had an underscore yeah could
you just go okay go to your page nah nah
here it is right all right underscore
fl underscore fl oh oh
you got it spell florence all right so
florence
r-e-n-c uh-huh and m-a-e that's right
yeah there it is
look how asian she is she's asian thank
you i'm not lying i'm not lying i'm not
like you but her last name is
exploring i think you said the last name
was floyd may is very she's not your
best friend
so you thought her last name was wait
what's her no no no she reversed it you
thought of her last name also her name
is may florence
yeah um she reversed it i know my best
friend
y'all best friends bro yes so you may
tell me she's your best friend
yeah i met her through comedy 2021 smile
more laugh more dance more
sing more have fun enjoy life that's not
some asian [ __ ]
is that not something that's some white
girl that's a white girl
that's a quote live life love guys yeah
live live but she she took it
that yeah more more and more yeah and
literally she
sucks that she eat the bone yeah
all right yeah i got yeah we got two
mini wings dog yeah
yeah yeah what are you trying to do if
i'm on the 20 wings
yeah what's she doing right there with
this right here which one talk about
this one
it's a little darker though yeah okay we
ain't got to do all that all right
wait what was the quote what was the
quote on that one yeah come on now
let's go
there's nothing more rare nor more
beautiful than a woman being on
unapologetically unapologetically
herself comfortable and giving myself
more luck
you know she's struggling i'd reach out
to your friend yeah this is 12 that's
good that's what these quotes are yeah
pour into your cup and fill it up before
you fill anyone else is up hashtag love
yourself you need to reach out to her
yeah
okay you got to reach out to me still
bro yeah you're right this is that's
crying come on now she did all that
i'm a fan buddy yeah she's crying for
help yeah follow along
she seems like a great person she is but
she crying for help listen
end of story get her an air fryer dog
get her an air fryer
so she can see no i don't have one
i've only eaten food that other people
have made me from there unreal do you
have one chin
no but i just talked to my girlfriend
about this her family bought one and
they didn't like it
they didn't have the experience you guys
had what do you mean they said it wasn't
good they didn't cook they don't know
what the [ __ ] they're doing
possible unreal what brand would you
recommend cruising let me ask joe what
brand ours is okay
because there's a few like ninja makes
one cuisinart i wish i
was shopping oh yeah
you can put a turkey in there no i want
to get one that fits i think some people
have made like small roasted chickens in
there
yeah i'm never conventional oven no way
never again never you look at it yeah at
air fryer ultimately
i just hate cleaning yeah you guys
messing with dvds i got streaming
you don't have it you have an air dryer
i'm out here at red box dog
you blog
yo it's awkward between my girl now this
weekend wow
why something went down like he's kind
of like what'd you do does it have to do
with the lube
nah bruh so she was working on this like
shoot big shoot
and you know we haven't been spending a
lot of time together because she's
working because she's working okay
i'm in the bathroom watching movies what
wait why are you watching boys are you
talking
[ __ ] no you're in the bathroom watching
movies oh
okay you're jacking it yeah oh right
yeah in her crib right
i didn't know she was home and then you
know you got the sound out loud
and i just hear her like drop her back
i'm like oh
shoot then she was like i was like are
you home she's like yeah i'm home
and now i know she heard me watching
movies of course so she goes uh i was
like yo she was like what are you doing
in there i was like you know what she
saw him
taking her you know taking a dump and
all that she was like okay cool and
she'd been quiet like the whole thing oh
no
oh she knew anything why didn't you just
why did you just tell her you was
jacking off
well because women that's awkward yeah
exactly you don't like that no i don't
care
no what you don't care about you don't
care i think everybody
has to masturbate at one point or
another i think it's normal get your
pleasure i'd rather you tell me now i
feel like you're hiding something yeah
yeah i'd rather you watch it i'm sure
she'd
prefer you're watching some professional
than like then like
absolutely watching a home video yeah if
she heard that back and forth dialogue
with you and some other girl
over face time then yeah that's gonna
get weird if that's what are you
watching you're watching like
some asian [ __ ] video
let us know what you like the german
blue girls
suggestions you might like when have i
said i like chicks with this
when have i ever gave you the idea that
your first year
big chance with big games what about a
bbw
when have i ever ever clicked on that oh
gosh come on i was about to say it
that's you
yeah i i did that like yeah what's your
genre yeah i like bbws i like oh what
you do
my thing is the dancing bear
bro so it's like all these women in this
office right and they clapping
and it's like stripper come out with a
whole bear that's what they
uh he'll just put some uh cream on his
penis and he'll just come up to the girl
[ __ ] they're like oh oh i guess it's my
turn to suck dick
into that yeah it's weird you know
you're in a furries i'm in a group
activity you're in a furry you're in the
group actually
you're in a furry what's furry is like
people in costumes having sex
no no not because there's no cosplay
yeah uh
furries are more like mascot costumes
like animals
yeah rather than like it's like a man in
a beer suit getting sucked off yeah yeah
i don't know i took the hell no you know
you [ __ ] up right
what do you mean cause you said yeah you
said a guy in a beer suit
and a bunch of girls bear helmet yeah
yeah yeah that's that's
that's furries well because no because
he's on brand dancing bear
you see what i'm saying he's on no
matter what you want to call it still a
man in the costume getting sucked off
and that's what you're into that's funny
he goes down he goes in a circle he goes
they're all because they're all the
women
they're like yeah but he takes the
helmet off when he like he reveals
what's the rest of his body
yeah is he in the bear costume no no
he's just naked but naked he come out
with this cream and he only
that's insane you're into that yeah yeah
of all things yeah don't tell your girl
this
yeah because now i'm concerned
we need to reach out to you this is why
you shouldn't tell your girl now
why so [ __ ] go down when you don't do
that
yeah you probably need to lie though
yeah i would lie yeah a lot
y'all don't do the oh yeah she didn't
want to do the dark eyeliner man i'm not
important actually it's not weird that
he watches this bear [ __ ] because he got
a pretty
good he got that gag ball thing so you
should be watching like dominatrix like
yeah
yeah but we lived that though you live
yeah you want something she got the mask
she got a mask like that [ __ ] she
know how to match and she was quite
offended that y'all
brought that up i told her i was like
she wants the mask no she doesn't want
the man yeah she does
yes she does okay but you're going to
get the gag ball you want the mask no
you put it but if you're
you got to elevate yourself if you're
watching something different would your
girl be offended if it was just like all
black on black
because she's obviously not black she's
not a fan she doesn't care she won't
kill this big fat black chick
she you know is that you yeah i think
she's like this way you're into it you
feel like fat because we
teach justin all the
again pouring in relationships is always
going to be weird and we do everything
you know y'all do everything yeah for
real we spice it up
do you yeah with luke i mean well yeah
the loop take it to a different
level huh oh you owe me money i mean you
owe me shoes bruh
i know we talked about it we talked
about that where was that man yeah you
remember i lost your back you're trying
to get off
your little masturbation that's fine
yeah i'd be careful on the on the beer
costume is a little strange yeah that's
true
he takes the he takes the hell out of it
yeah it's just weird is that your is
that something you wish you could have
done it's like
it's an office setting bro it's like
different places so it's like a
bachelorette it's an office
it's a uh what else divorce parties
whatever it is yeah you you know
familiar with it yeah i've seen it yeah
i've never seen it yeah i sat through
and watched it you ever watched that you
ever watched the english guy driving the
taxi
i love that all right come on where are
you where are you
let's say i just pull you over right two
stops on the airport and just like
banks oh bank bang they call it yeah he
goes in and he'd be killing them he's
having no conversation she's like oh i'm
trying to get here he's like that's 17
or and i'm like hell yeah
you're like i fast forward through all
the talk bro yeah [ __ ] that
public uh public agent uh bro it's like
a guy acts like he's a public
public agent agent yeah so he ain't like
oh you're a model you get like these
girls like beautiful off the street he
was like yo
can you model for me i give you like
like 10 000 c
uh euros okay cool like all right but
you have to go to the bushes and she's
alright cool 10 000.
and they bad and then he's like yo for
30 000 let me see your titty
and she got that kind of money on wrong
like this [ __ ] didn't he say like fake
but yeah oh it's awful
yeah oh yeah i'm sorry
he got lost in the sauce
yeah like that and there's multiple
videos of him giving them cash like that
[Laughter]
and i only agree that's all fake i'm
over here feeding into them
the taxi guy's not a real tattoo
the camera just somehow be there bro i'm
so sorry i don't know what the [ __ ] i
was thinking
but i was like damn 30 000 yeah
all right how's that only fans going cat
uh it's good
bro still climbing yeah it's good you
saw it she told us
oh before yeah ballet cast about it
i'm gonna we gotta do something yeah we
gotta do something you guys gotta do
something
wait what what do you wanna do i was
thinking me and
uh she says the collaborations are only
fan so i'm thinking like me and cat like
rolly cat
or something like that that's so sexual
though now that
like i think of it because the collabs
are sexual though yeah i want to see a
cloud for you in your big day because
it's usually like collabs with two girls
it's like oh you hannah mojo or like um
and like lana rhodes there's like a lot
of porn stars doing collabs with each
other on their only fans
i don't know about like guys doing
collabs actually now that i think i
don't know if the guy
fans would be into you clapping with him
yeah that's another thing like
i mean one you would need to build a
following you know
what are you very specific demographic
yeah what the [ __ ] would you do on only
family i'm showing dude
[Music]
and then chin just start singing yeah
i'm in there just like doing the wet
willy with my it'll be cool
willie the celebrity the airplane
bella uh tiger biting trying to be doing
the damn thing
has a whole modeling agency on only fans
now of just like ig thoughts
yeah what was that guy i don't know uh
he was on teen wolf he's got a [ __ ]
he was uh bella thorne's ex-boyfriend
who posted a
nude video yeah playing guitar guitar he
took our ideas playing guitar yeah
serious yeah i know i know
what's up [ __ ] i got to work out we
know that
who's this sonia morgan from housewives
oh you know
what's she doing bro she like black men
4.99 a month oh you know aaron carter's
on there oh intercourse
yeah he lost oh he did like a live
concert naked
like a stream he streamed a live concert
look at his prizes 27.
he made his porn debut yeah things are
going well for him
what was that drag queen oh yeah yeah
from what root balls 4.99 a month i
could be killing it
nights twenty a month twenty dollars a
month oh black child
is good thirty she has one thirty wait
she she originally was a stripper
yes originally she started off his
district
another housewives uh dorinda you know
all these girls yes she's from new york
they all
what she got the only fans for these
women just probably just like sells
fitness cooking yes decorating yeah oh
i'm not paying for that
tanya who's that that's tana mojo yeah
she is a youtuber she's one of those
girls who makes like millions a month
yeah she shows news huh she's jake paul
girl he'd be killing it
amber yeah ambrose is on there that's
the actor right there right who the [ __ ]
is that
he was a singer man only fans bums
it's kind of sad we're just looking at
all d-less celebrities
okay bring it back up jordan wood is not
bad she has a only fans
yeah but she don't possibly you're the
one who uh who used to look like me yeah
20 a month i'll pay for that chris brown
he's just drawing stuff on there though
20 bucks michael b jordan oh yeah he
talked about it right
yeah yeah some celebrities aren't doing
like fun stuff on there
oh we talked about this earlier fat joy
dj khaled yep they have one for twenty
dollars
interesting damn all right what current
events you got jen cat
here we go okay so first one you
you had a hand in this eminem uh ended
up posting a new song called hire onto
youtube and a lot of the pr was
surrounded by this clip
and you're in there too huh just a few
days ago branch after your brief clip
appeared to be eminem dana white back
and forth on sportscenter where marshall
mathers absolutely
i wouldn't say destroys dana in that
um yeah man don't play first
sure the best part about your opinion is
that it doesn't matter
and if every fighter that you had
listened to your opinion when you
doubted them
you wouldn't have a leak so um the best
part about your opinion
he said you wouldn't have a [ __ ]
league it was all uh i would stand and
say here
one last thing what happened with eminem
last night
why why do you ask i don't know it seems
like there's a clip going around and it
seemed like there was something going on
yeah there's something going on you'll
have to wait and see
all right okay with that thank you dana
yeah it was all just a lead up to create
hype for
his new uh music video dana was
on it ufc's in on it i was in on it
look at you guys you sent the song in
the group chat it's pretty cool yeah
it's cool
oh i didn't listen to it it was like
five minutes oh five minutes song
yeah i know from eminem it's a lot
eminem looks good though it looks like
he's taking care of himself
he looks very healthy yeah it's really
good good for him he's sober right
yeah yes sober and
that was the album recovery that's what
he was talking about yep
his sobriety they're smart with the way
they work man it's smart
create the buzz he seems like a good
dude
yeah for sure that's what's up man
okay next one this one is depressing
um larry king passed away this past
weekend at 87. is it though
is it he's 87.
why 80. it's a what a great run
he had a great i don't think it was that
sad him or hank aaron it's like
is it though yeah great ron dude right
wrong
87 87 that's long average age
no most people don't make it historic
career man legend
worked until he was like eighties so how
much i mean what are old people diamond
that's
that's the game we're all going to get
there you know 87
great run great run
yeah i want to i want to
one of the greatest broadcasters of all
time i appreciate him
uh but i was i saw a post that uh they
had
i don't know it's again social media
they ranked they ranked like who's the
top
uh uh broadcast or whatever what an
analyst i should say he's on analyst
he's not what is he a broadcaster right
uh interviewer oh interviewer all right
so pierce
morgan sent the dis shot well pierce
took over for larry king
uncied oh god so they had beef with that
yeah he kind of said this shot but it
was also kind of like
you know yes and no they had beef
because he took over for larry king
oh did you see that did you see this
honestly i'm a pierce morgan fan oh
so you said it wasn't really not a lot
of this or anything uh not really it
wasn't too bad
he had he had a lot of uh i think he had
a heart attack that he
uh he survived he had a yeah he had a
heart attack he had
cancer he had covered he beat all he
made a lot of [ __ ]
he beat a lot of [ __ ] legends legend
yeah
yeah he had a good run yeah i was like
yeah diagnosed with lung cancer
man i'm still here i'm still kicking ass
legend man he interviewed every
anyone too yeah anybody he was great
yeah
we'll never get to hear him fart ever
again oh yeah you farted on you got
older just don't give a [ __ ] yeah
okay so we talked about the bernie
sanders meme last week
and bernie ended up monetizing off of
that by
making them into sweaters and all of the
proceeds from his sweaters went to
vermont's meals on wheels
they sold out within i think an hour or
two oh [ __ ]
oh yeah a few hours yeah that'd be an
easy shirt to do
yeah yeah i know you're just sitting
there how old is bernie is he up there
as well he's up there
78 they're all yeah he's on the court
he's like 78.
am i right almost eight oh he just
turned 79 yeah look at the president
78. like damn maybe around the corner
bro
wow he was six feet tall jesus bernie
yeah
whoa six feet holy moly i'm sure like
he hunches over so he doesn't look as
tall but still i don't know
i thought he was like five six right
same he looks small
i didn't realize trump was that tall
trump a big dude yeah yeah
i didn't realize he was like yeah six
three these guys grew up with larry king
bro
think about that biden was on larry king
like 1986.
damn crazy
shout out for him getting his money who
getting his money uh
joe biden six foot tall mm-hmm well all
that money no he donated he don't donate
to the meals on wheels
yeah what else did he say so
this was submitted by
yeah this was submitted by trav
etra 808 on instagram they want you to
react to this bike trick gone wrong
[Music]
look at his face
[Music]
oh
that must have [ __ ] hurt not the back
shot
boom boom oh
damn and his head
[Music]
was the kid okay we don't know no one
knows
we don't i know he had a headache stupid
stunt just to begin with
yeah the juggling yeah it's like yeah
then he gets the best thing about that
is him getting tired of the face
hey can we see that guy again he look
like jeremiah watkins who riding a bike
i think his at is right there oh he kind
of does is that jeremiah
it does yeah from the side the nose kind
of looks
like everything that no yeah forget
about that
i can't forget about what british i
forget about that
but her nose is too bad but that knows
oh he posted the clip oh so he's like a
famous uh
he's a pro it looks like freestyle
freestyle
mountain bike athlete i hope that dude
didn't like
that [ __ ] out that [ __ ] look like a
[ __ ] i guess i guess he posted i'm
pretty sure the guy is fine if he posted
it
oh he's russian all right he is right
that's why this is what happens blah
blah blah
some
let's see what he does lifts oh [ __ ]
oh
[Laughter]
right
so floyd mayweather he mentions connor
you know connor talks all this crap and
that's kind of what floyd mayweather
does but
with his money and stuff yeah but
floyd's hated by people and he says
that's because of racism
because conor's white and he's black let
me read this phrase and give me your
take on it he goes i've seen the post
and my take on it is that this world
knows conor
mcgluzer can steal everything from me
and be loved but i'm hated
that just lets you all know that racism
still exists just know that
that bomb will never be me or my my
level i'm a natural born winner and yes
i took a lot of trash but every time i
back up that's why they hate
it's sad that you can be a poor black
kid from the ghetto that has dealt with
racism your whole life
and work extremely hard to put yourself
and your family a better position and
most of the hate comes from my own
people
where are you at on this uh you did the
press run with him and he always felt
like mcgregor
like took his style and i it's not
racism i just think that
sure is [ __ ] not racist yeah i just
think that he just
he just gets upset that connor is
beloved
that his you know persona and he
basically did the same thing
like floyd like i'm gonna beat his bad
guy hold
conor never beat uh any women
no oh you talking about 2002 no but i'm
talking about the chris
connor has no domestic violence okay
yeah that is true that would be a reason
the public doesn't [ __ ] with you
that is true and then also how are you
going to say that it's racist but he did
hit that old dude
in the bar again conor's never been
accused domestic
domestic violence at least he's never
been to jail charged officially and went
to prison for it you know
domestic violence america does not play
with no nobody plays
maybe some like russian or china might
but the world does not mess with
domestic violence
floyd mayler went to prison for domestic
violence
his baby mama is dead yeah
you know what i'm saying like that's
that's who he went to joe
baby mama yeah yeah jo jo uh he's gonna
write a tell-all book she's gone
so but you what what's weird here is he
goes oh it's racism blah blah blah
but then i'm getting hate on by my own
people
well that acts that out because if you
didn't hate on by your own people
it wouldn't be racism if black people
are hating on you well and also anybody
who's that famous i don't care who you
are lebron
drake leonardo dicaprio [ __ ] jordan
tiger woods anyone who's that famous in
that space any big comic chappelle
there's going to be hate there's going
to be that famous is going to be you
can't please everybody
so for floyd to say oh i have hate like
yeah yes hate
yeah but outside the ring is
why maybe people don't [ __ ] with them a
hundred percent
i give you that i think his own people
doesn't mess with again i mess with
floyd it's my man but i think that
he doesn't speak up enough for like
injustice
that's going on and a lot of people like
yo you donate you flashing money i
remember when
like again with the george floyd
situation he went out on his post and
was like yo i'm on a yacht
you know during quarantine and stuff
like that so yeah that's that's like
that's just
that but that's floyd though that's just
him well that's awesome it's him
persona yeah that one's bad like that
that's just not knowing the temperature
of the room
like you didn't yeah in the room but
that's why that's why i think like the
inner
but again with this crown of mcgregor in
this situation i just think that he just
he's just upset that someone had similar
uh personality yes because he he
definitely took the style from him
exactly and that's why
being showboated flashy for sure and
conor has more fans
than floyd i mean i should say more fans
that love him
than hate him and floyd has a lot of
people we watch floyd to see him
you know fail and that's why he trained
so hard so i think yeah but there's also
too
when floyd got to a certain point his
fights weren't exciting
yeah he's super defensive fighter which
i think i would do the exact same thing
as
if i was him but his fights weren't
exciting nah so everyone's paying to
watch him lose
then you talk all that [ __ ] um but also
as an american fighter the international
fighters are always kind of more beloved
too because america we have two so many
stars
yeah we have too many but yeah like so
like maybe floyd want to be the face of
i don't know pepsi or some [ __ ] but
america we got too many stars done
i mean name another star out of violence
yeah you know what i'm saying so conor
is
ireland so that small nation supports
the [ __ ] out of him i find it weird
though like he always races me
here's and here's my other problem it's
racism what happens when you say racism
when he doesn't speak up for all these
other injustices
and they say this is racism well you
hurt the actual
take on racism when there's real
systematic racism
when you say this racism and you're so
far off you've
actually hurt you don't move the needle
you're not moving it forward
yeah i agree i i i see what you're
saying but almost racism
okay most of hate comes from my own
people that's it yeah that is how do you
not have someone in your crew to [ __ ]
look at what you're posting me like well
you contradict yourself here dude
exactly makes sense well what do let me
ask you a question does it ever bother
you that before the
and again we domestic dispute or
domestic violence that yeah
but before 2010 he you never seen floyd
in sponsors you never seen him on
commercials you've never seen him do it
no one picked him up you see like what
connor's
sponsors or of manny pacquiao nike
you've never seen floyd
in that light you always see him you
know him from boxing whose fault is that
what do you mean whose fault is that the
publix no because he's the most
sponsored athlete in the world
who the uh james yeah yeah lebron james
but lebron james is in love like
if brian love lebron has more haters
than floyd
yeah he's more famous he's more so the
bigger you are the more haters you're
gonna have
i'm just saying you can't say it's a
black problem they don't have more
sponsors
nah but but it's a boxing process no i'm
saying it's a boxing problem he took
that persona though he took that
that bad guy persona and he paid for it
but
he also made a lot of money boxing but
if you're going to be the bad guy
yeah people like pepsi and coke and
walmart they don't want to [ __ ] with the
bad guy but the bad guy made a lot of
money
so what do you complain about i think
he's obviously not racism they just
don't they're going to sponsor this guy
instead of this guy
but in boxing no boxer has big
sponsorships
what pacquiao did like nike at the time
of heidi's career at nike
other than that what boxers like really
like sponsored like the face of [ __ ]
roy jones for a little bit mike tyson
never got [ __ ]
nah mike tyson was at the end he went to
prison but he he was going i think he
was on a pike to be the next face of
boxing
but even like nope like no boxers really
getting like mainstream
like notoriety and sponsors yeah i see
what you said but again
base you you'll see a box okay well it's
good let's say you own
uh so let's say your merch takes off
okay you have millions and millions of
dollars
and you can decide do you want to work
with
so we so who's a who's a big boxer
current that you like
let's just say uh canelo alvarez he has
sponsors
different he's the face of mexico earl
spence earl spence good one okay
so let's say you have 10 million dollar
sponsor earl spence which we know his
fights don't draw a lot of attention
maybe he's sold out okay they don't it
doesn't
all right let's see if it equals the
sales there's a reason why we're like
like terence crawford amazing
yeah amazing boxers yeah doesn't equal
pay-per-view sales no so you have a 10
million dollars work with earl spence
or you can give the money over here to
dustin poirier you can give the money to
jon jones
uh is your israel out of sanya guys who
we know when they fight you're getting
two four million views
so it's it's it's like boxing just
there's not but it goes back to when
it's just not
it goes back to the superstar and too
many like it's not enough stars in
boxing
here's the other problem with floyd and
floyd's this big what do you mean he's
this big
oh too sure no one wants to be floyd oh
yeah like you know
like it's not inspiring i got this all
right this little small guy
who wears this he's not knocking dudes
out like he's not a knockout artist
still putting little lips in his foot
yeah he's a small person too so
the smaller guy never gets sponsors
even in even the ufc the smaller guys
don't get the same what the other guys
get
they just don't yeah no one gives a [ __ ]
about small guys okay
well yeah oh and that's why i was just
like it was just bugged me out that he
never really had sponsors
and that's a boxing small guy thing and
if you want to be the bad guy
also he doesn't need sponges he's making
so much money being the bad guy
people paying to watch him lose who
gives a [ __ ] about sponsors
if you're making that yeah that much
money then what is it he made the right
choice by not [ __ ] sponsored being in
the back because he's made so much money
exactly i just think he's a small guy
too many yes men around you
to just like around yes name a white guy
if you want to talk about racism name a
white guy who's balling and
boxing they got sponsors it's not too
many white guys i mean caleb plant is
fire i like him but not too young
why not like face of nike or nah nah nah
i remember mike lee didn't even do
anything he was to face the subway that
boxer
mike lee remember that yeah notre dame
yeah i mean kind of yeah that's that's
the great white i
hope that was calling but i'm saying
again
probably be the biggest we're getting
but you you said english yeah he's
saying
we're talking about that great white
hope yeah mike lee he had a subway he
was a face of subway
and it was uh putting a lot of
sponsorship behind it
but um yeah see he had like what three
four this is when uh they
but they did a few fights they did a few
athletes on that campaign
he wasn't like the guy he was at like
lebron for nike
he was he was one of the guys i know
what you're saying yeah
but i get again it's a boxing problem
yeah and
like i said go to your sample your point
yeah floyd has too many like yes man
around until like hey bro just chill out
you know i mean clown connor or whatever
but you know bringing up the race oh
people
people are just like yeah do that put
that out there well yeah racism angle
that it didn't make sense
yeah think about it look at your [ __ ]
tweet or instagram
it all he goes it's a shame to see that
all comes from my people
i mean racism that is it they just don't
like you yeah fish don't [ __ ] with you
yeah
poor black kids it's a you problem this
ain't a race problem
hold on it's a poor black kid from the
ghetto
with racism your whole life
wait wait where did he say uh oh oh he i
think he's
most the hate comes from my own people
but he's saying he's being hated on
be and that connor's so loved but then
he says the hate comes from my own
people that's not racism yeah
[Music]
all right bro i like floyd but you know
he's made a lot of mistakes
shout out and also but if you're a small
boxer no one you know
known for it and dejuan said chill out
with the uh floyd killing his wife's
stuff that's what he said
who's dwane uh he's only his cousin his
right hand man all right well don't kill
people
chill out don't give your axes fentanyl
at nine in the morning you really
believe that though i do think you gotta
hand it yeah i do
yeah i do you know they postponed uh
jake for uh his fight with
you know why i know why why i know why
well why you know what people don't give
a [ __ ]
i know wait what happened yeah the logan
paul floyd mayweather they did
they did like a a pre like sale where
you get it cheaper
early and there's just no interest no
one cares but but
listen why is that i i i don't think
it's because people aren't interested in
floyd and
logan paul i think there's so much i
don't think it's as much interest as
they think
yeah i think people like that's kind of
a [ __ ] circus act i think
we're not conditioned to pay for paper
never in the history have we paid for a
pay-per-view early
so people like i don't know what the
[ __ ] i'm doing when is it so interesting
is that
i think it's part of that but i also
think part of it maybe people are done
with these circus acts you know yeah no
i think if you default jake paul i think
it had been do you agree with that if
you're the far jake paul no i don't
i don't think it matters i i literally i
i think to
the business plan to sell papers early
just doesn't we've never done that
america we don't do that no no so like
they're trying to reinvent pay-per-view
and be like wait i'm not paying for it
early would you well i
they should just continue to go on and
see what the sales were like at the
start
i think that you gotta have tank davis
on that cart give me
tank davis in a in another fight make it
a real car ryan garcia oh it's just
gotta be a real it has to be a real car
but
also i think he'd have made more money
because look how jake paul is calling
out connor
he just came knocked out nate robinson
he'd had
more attraction with that fight than his
brother logan paul who's old one in one
do you know what i mean
that's all i'm saying got it i i just
think that
maybe maybe it's a pay-per-view setup
problem or they're trying to reinvent
the way you buy papers
or maybe people are just like dude we
want real [ __ ] you think kids are like
dude
floyd we're not giving you money to
watch you fight this youtuber like give
us some real [ __ ] he already robbed it
so many times
yeah that makes sense could be that they
over
what else you got you mentioned this i
thought it was interesting because you
mentioned that
uh patrick mahomes wouldn't be cleared
but then he was cleared
suspect the baby goat the baby goat
what do you why do you think it's man
suspect yeah it's just
now so um [ __ ] clay
uh travis clay traps has his doctor on
uh dr chin it might be chin or chow dr
chow
and he was like he doesn't think it's a
concussion he thought it was like a
nerve in the neck which shuts off
everything
so he was like i don't think it's a
concussion because his head didn't hit
hard enough
but they said when they took him back to
do the concussion test he missed some
[ __ ]
you know i've been around concussions
that to me was a concussion you said he
was yeah
there's no way he could be a hundred
percent and come back do you have the
video
he balled out yeah he balled up he
balled out but you emphasize like yo
that is a concussion i guarantee i think
100 is a concussion
you know but to get to the super bowl
they're going to do whatever they got to
do
and listen that's the best way with the
baby ghost he's so [ __ ] good
you see how his arm is stiff yeah you
see how his arm stiff
right now his arm is stiff on top note
for a second and look when he gets up to
say this is
nerve is interesting to me
and then he failed questions during the
protocol i don't know dude
let's see watch his left arm the left
forearm all right
see how watch it goes like this see how
it's different oh
okay and then he's out there yeah see
how his arm's still tight is he's still
making a fist
yeah you get knocked out that's what
happens oh
so i don't know
he's still through 325 yards super ball
yeah so if with that being said
like okay say yeah they didn't let him
like
clear how long does that like healing
proc
ufc it's like 60 to 90 days you get
knocked out it's usually 90 days
yeah you got to be football football get
a football yeah
football well you're the best player in
the game and the
the afc championship football gonna
football he didn't get sacked right you
played
he didn't get he didn't get touched
didn't do any of that running nothing he
didn't really run
nope he stayed in the pocket and balled
out bro he's kind of passing the torch
mahomes to brady we sat there in the
group chat i thought i was tripping but
i wasn't
no he he's not the goat oh he's not okay
no he's not the goat not yet i saw you
asked that i didn't ask that question
people shut me down i'm like yo if you
win he just has to do more
but look you know this tom brady's 10th
super ball park
wait three years three years this guy's
record like we can go over his eyes
i think if he gets to fi like once you
get five and [ __ ] like dude what if you
go like four and no
like let's say he wins the super bowl
which he will right and he wins the next
super bowl three-peat
right like the cowboys back then and
then he wins another super bowl is he to
go
uh four super bowls four four four four
get them there
okay four four we're gonna close i
believe well captain
he has way more talent than uh yeah but
but we know casp
space is not gonna do that but if he
continues to win with different guys
yeah in that system with andy reid he's
a beast yeah wait uh so wait
are you guys betting on this one are you
guys what are you who do you have i mean
i got the baby go you got the real one
oh i have to see it's too tough huh
it's too thick it's too good i give you
points what's the spread chin
it's they started up at three plus right
oh come on i need more than three points
give me time
i'm glad people are seeing this that's
just vegas eyes right here
just buffalo bills in canada
super bowl [ __ ] it's so
[ __ ] funny it is so funny i don't
know the sports
this spread right here i say bill still
no no it goes uh
bucks are plus 430 they're four to one
dog
oh no that's not let's go yeah that's
not the s4 is it only three go to
draftkings for me go to draftkings for
me
there it is draftkings yeah yeah
points for it
minus three and a half i need ten nah
bro three and a half two one with vegas
give me ten i'll do it
are you you hear
i like the i like the over on the 57. i
think it goes over on both sides
yeah both defenses i mean i bet that
casey's defense pretty good but
i like to over if anything no i i would
have not bet against uh mahomes
they're too good yeah you can't yeah
that's wasting money
any tampa i don't know if they should
even be there i felt like
green bay the coach [ __ ] up with the
kick in a field goal so we talked
about that yeah but again roger is so
disappointed
yeah he saw him after the game yeah he
has three years left on his contract
they said he'll probably ask for a trade
algebra i say the brady route and desean
watson's getting out too
what do you think and they just i want
aaron rodgers or deshawn watson come to
la ramps with our defense
we're going [ __ ] scissors but we got
number one defense
golf all that money i know we gotta cut
him
oh my god and then and then it's houston
going to take that big contract
yeah if we trade them nah but deshawn
watson has a fat contract too
huge but i'll make more money per year
than patrick would you rather have you
did say that would you rather have
desean watson or jared goff i'll talk to
sean watson
rogers okay deshawn watson
right here over allen of course overall
yeah probably
are you serious probably josh allen come
on man and we had to throw what did
johnny wilson
over russell oh i don't know russell is
like all right
he's older though i got russ i got rust
number four
and then i have allen and josh allen
yeah
i can't base off one game josh allen
balled out this year he had a great year
and
every year he's progressing i give you
that but i'm just saying he's not top
three
no top three yeah not even all right
i see chappelle trying to get in on it
he said i'm with you we did a whole fist
but i don't even notice that i don't i
don't respect anybody
it's just it felt weird
[Laughter]
this is related to it um this is the guy
that this is my home's mom and the guy
that hit
mahomes they were going back and forth
on twitter number 51 evil never
it was a hard tackle like it's a
standard tackle
no disrespect mom i just i'm just
playing hard it's a danish game we play
and we take risks every time we step a
foot on the field
probably that pat is okay but mind you
i've never been a dirty player i just
want to win and be great like your son
that's a great one that's a great
response that's a great response she
responded back to really nice but i
can't find that freaking tweet oh she
did but also mom stay off twitter yeah
exactly yeah
too what's up with mom evil never that's
not eve that's a standard tackle that's
not the only evil was the stupid play
call
yeah yeah evil brown's
lying back not stop stupid what else you
got he said mom stay off twitter yeah
this is called the salmon cannon and
check it out
i've seen these before they launched
salmon into the rivers
so it takes it from the lower waterways
and above the dam so they can spawn
so it's helping them out instead of you
know trying to go up a dam and dying
oh that's cool yeah all right how cool
is that
yeah whoosh
what do you think of this brendan
cool man check it out you asked we've
seen this
now you do that on purpose you try to
set them up
[Laughter]
[Music]
it always feel like it's really just be
like yeah
what else you got chances
salmon it's going down
it's going down that little nile river
river oh go go back to the one of the
headlines it looks like it's trying on
twitter what you're just on
says what's happening so uh trending
trending in the united states kaepernick
as tom brady makes his way to another
super bowl some football fans will point
out that ooh i can't
i love this some football fans point out
that the quarterback's politics is
friendship with donald trump
have derailed his career in the way
haven't derailed his career in the way
that colin kaepernick's peaceful
protests
of police violence did arguably into his
exit from the nfl there's
one problem cabernet's not [ __ ] good
at football
he's not very good tom brady's the goat
so what are you gonna do i got you
brenden tom brady in the first half
played great but in the second half he
played like he wanted to be out okay
the defense came and saved them to the
super bowl but again he has anything
nothing to do with kaepernick or or tom
brady's relationship with donald trump
no the guy balled out in the first half
no no
this is very black and white one is good
at football
one is not yeah but again you knew that
was going to come
as soon as like his affiliation with
donald trump you knew those like tweets
was going to come out like you knew that
again one's good at football i don't
give a [ __ ] if pastor my homes celebrate
satan every sunday if he's playing like
that i
don't give a [ __ ] if he's playing for my
team
i don't give a [ __ ] if he's drinking
goat blood the night before the game
dude i don't care if he's sucking off
seven dudes
if he's throwing the ball like that i
don't know why anybody gives a [ __ ]
but that kaepernick argument's insane
one's good at football
the other's just not yeah the other
became the face
of the the black movement and he doesn't
he didn't want that he don't care
he does he's not even educated i think
without saying him speak up on anything
important
oh he's talking about like kaepernick
cabernet no he about the he don't care
about football
i think fans throw that in there like
that's not kaepernick team like let's
get the
let's get the race back was he not good
though for real no he was
he was good he's a jared goff you
remember no
jericho when he took him he took he did
the same if you really look at it they
had the same career jared goff went to
the super bowl
he went to the super bowl they both lost
they ball up like and then
jared goff is not like that he's not
jared goff can throw the pigskin
cabernet can't he's not very accurate
and then he he was he he was a run he
his legs got him a lot a lot of wins and
then yeah then it happens
every year whether it happened to uh
your boy um not lamar jackson
no not lamar they'll catch up with him
but it happened to um
oh i knew rg3 rg3 yeah where they run
all the time they're like oh damn this
dude
he's gonna be the face of the franchise
and the nfl goes all right
cool you're a runner we're gonna shut
all that down and you're forced to use
fundamentals
and throw the football and they don't
pass the test cameron's just a guy
you're right yeah there's a million of
them you're right he's just a guy
and then he comes with all this pressure
they're like yeah we're good man
golf is better than no gear gothic
fundamentally he's a better throw yeah
you're right better
i'm tripping i bother they both trash
i don't want neither
[Applause]
doesn't come with all this all this like
like kaepernick's a backup at best
but he's a famous backup the same thing
happened with tim tebow
yeah is tim tebow good enough playing
the nfl [ __ ] yeah he took him
he won a playoff game he beat the
pittsburgh steelers but as a backup he's
more famous than the starters so there's
always going to be pressure
to play him they don't want to deal with
it he's not good enough
tom brady's good enough whether he's a
trump supporter whether he celebrates
satan no one gives a flying [ __ ] he's
good yeah the roles be devilish i could
punch me in the face with this one but i
didn't know uh
antonio brown was playing again he
didn't play last game but yeah he
was hurt he'll play in the super bowl
though either way either way mike evans
step his [ __ ] game no no no now now i
get hurt
i know i get what you're saying that one
pass was overthrown okay no no but then
he dropped another one that was the
interception
he dropped the ball dude he barely it
was over his head he hit both his hands
it was way up have you never seen him
catch like
he said he used to play basketball he's
a joke he goes up that's his thing
so you mean tell me a brady threw out
throws his jumper
and it barely he barely can touch it he
has both hands on the ball yeah
right i'm again i'm trying to dial but
mike evan's been hurt this whole season
he's not a hundred percent
i'm dying on arguments i don't care
about it i'm the chiefs fan oh that's it
oh yeah i'm a sophist you know yeah
i get it i get it bro but i'm not about
to die on some limbs i don't care about
but i get what you're saying
yeah yeah uh squads in texas man san
marcos texas 10 tickets left total for
all shows uh two shows friday the 29th
two shows saturday the 30th
the mark texas special guest gonna be a
fun one man
texas this friday saturday san marcos
texas
then tampa florida february 26 to the
27th that's a friday and saturday in
tampa florida
tickets at f a t k z dot com
thick boy collab with specialized that
is a limited run it's not like our other
merch where we just keep printing and
making them
it's a limited run because with
specialized so get the long sleeves and
black and white the short sleeve and the
water bottle
they restock the thick boy smiling merch
go to thickboy.com
right now get it and we will see you
guys wednesday we out
what's up man they call me chappelle
where's the same jeans lacy you know
what i'm saying
yeah cause i got one pair these are the
bands made by uh donnie
donnie just dude out of yeah
brooklyn donnie out of brooklyn man go
to go see donnie in brooklyn
you know about these shoes you know the
vans
escape what's up what's up help me find
some jeans
sorry that was aggressive y'all love it
i'm like
getting money from me oh wave chat
oh oh i'm hitting hard today chin
champion right now we're swimming you
see it yeah
what's going on coming in man ocean yeah
yeah yeah oh i just got the kobe's again
i know he's my favorite shoes are you
wearing the same shoes same shoes
and you're trying to keep up with the
trend give me some oh geez
yeah do you do shoe cam i'll tell you
after you did the meltdown bands again
yeah i have two pairs go ahead
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]